hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play EEB it
has been a long day of recording we've
got tons of stuff oh hello
tons of stuff coming at you soon but for
right now I'm very eager to get through
with EEB stairs I've come this far but
now I'm wondering if I should keep going
but I'm not sure what good going back
will do wait a minute
ah all these choices huh why wouldn't I
want to go ahead we could wait a minute
is that something is there something
that I need to get would I do I don't
think I need anything right no no hang
on hang on
oh maybe I need to go back to see what
um even the other lady the not human
girly warily is up to where's my portal
portal portal yours don't have a portal
is there any other reason that I would
need to explore I don't think so pretty
sure oh yeah I don't know why it gave me
the choice there I guess that just means
that the game is going to be not allow
me to come back yeah I got a stave just
in case let's go go for it
go ahead nothing will come from just
loading around please let her be safe I
know EEP we'll be safe but not in the
hands of that psycho maniac
yeah the portal is gone Mary Barry are
you okay yes I'm okay
am i okay okay okay okay jeez Oh Eve
okay Mary I'm okay marry me aha
that's weird
Mary Mary Mary uh where did Mary go ah
what what are you doing over there
Mary Mary what are you doing Mary I'm in
my way in my way in my way in my way
she's swinging a palette knife he's
swinging a palette she's gonna come
after the user key
Oh Eve don't leave me
Oh Oh I won't do you know about snow
I do wow that's nice it's really cold
right I read in a book that you could
eat it with syrup I wonder how it tastes
oh good I didn't know that I could talk
to you while falling a lot of people are
very concerned about me getting the
ending um but you have to remember that
I'm playing this you know completely
blind I don't have the benefit of
playing it multiple times or multiple
play playthroughs is some of you guys do
so I'm enjoying the story for what it is
and just let me I'm okay
I've always wanted a girl like me who
could be my friend
and I don't wanna meet your mom too I
mean I don't even have a dad that's
creepy
do you have friends like how many you
play with them right and sometimes you
argue maybe after you argue you can come
back as better friends than before I
wonder what Gary's doing now crying all
alone maybe hope we find him soon I want
to get out now I'm tired of being here
let's play the dolls I'll be the mom
doll need can be the dad doll why are a
dull suit what
is this just endless talk yeah okay
that's cycle through again alright so
what I have to do is I have to find a
way back to Gary did you murder that
thing what happened to it hello a
mannequin covered in wounds last not
good yes wait where did Mary go Mary
Mary Mary where'd you go I'm a little
concerned now hey you get out of the way
um Mary did I lose her did I somehow oh
she's over there Mary what Mary's
berry-berry okay oh yeah I forgot about
this
yeah yeah yeah hi it's been a few days
since I picked up this game again excuse
me if I'm a little distracted there
seemed to be some strains uncertainties
happening Mary Mary where'd you go
fine you know what Mary you just go
la-dee-da on your own are you going Eve
oh you know why are you going by
yourself we promised we'd be together
you kind of got it went away hey are you
ready babe what are you doing Mary shut
up if you had only just been good and
waited there Mary I knew it you're stay
away yeah why oh oh my doctor dot Eve
are you okay sorry I'm late so kit Gary
whoa Eva sorry it must have been scary
but it's okay now is it not so sure you
might not believe me but Mary she isn't
human she's one of where Tina's works
just like those paintings of women who
came after us I didn't spend enough time
with her to really notice it's dangerous
to stay with her even if I just been
here little later there you might feel a
bit sorry for her but we need to get
away now why Mary isn't moving a muscle
Mary's Bros is on the ground looks real
but it's fake
all right so what do we do now yes we
could save it would be good right okay
okay here we go oh wait no well where
are we supposed to go then no oh yeah
the statue that only Gary can move cuz
he's big and strong I think the stairs
go down all right Eve step back Oh mr.
muscles coming through just how many
statues have I pushed today oh well
let's go must be a big big ditch whoa
starry night whoa was that a ghost or a
shooting star
I'm gonna assume that's not a deadly
DOMA oh I see we've gone into insanity
mode now lovey the childlike wonder oh
my oh my I'm gonna assume that those
aren't good things they may look
fanciful and free now this is a
significant change in atmosphere nothing
we can't handle let's go even if you say
so Gary
hahahahahaha something out of a child's
nightmare really these are all
storybooks okay so nothing there that I
need to know about well this is
obviously from where Tina's early
childhood or something along those lines
that thing had the painting on it like
with the uh oh my what is that down what
is that that looks like EEB except it's
a doll of Eve
it's an Eve doll a doll EEB I'm not whoa
whoa I think I want that food hi snake
this disturbing the door is frozen over
okay this is also so weird but in a
different type of weird like there's a
weird that's creepy because it's
uncertain and unfamiliar this is just
creepy based on the context of what it
is like a child imagine that there's
another Eve doll yes what is that on the
floor ring okay you think I didn't even
need that oh that's a house what I just
stuffed in a toy box do you mean the toy
box is I'll even see a toy box I don't
even know what you're talking about
I think this is just a big square grid
if I'm not mistaken yeah it is but I
didn't see a toy box
I don't think I want to dip my rose into
that stare into it
he makes sure you don't fall in while
you're spacing out peel the water in my
Rosen ah crap damn it stupid dumb fine
whatever hours things have happened but
I don't know what I'm supposed to do I'm
kind of just I've gone into complete all
there's a house down here that I'm in
there we go oh this is lovely coat
hanger bunny rabbit
[ __ ] it I'll take that fill it with
water Hummer
hey Gary where are you oh boy
Oh
dot okay don't tell me that was she's
after us is she now
alright then but uh go fill this up with
water and do something with it I'm not
exactly sure what the pinkie is always
kept in the toy box so what about that
Oh what about do I need to wash
something off or something have a bucket
of crayon water what do I do about it
I'm soaking whoa things have changed I
can't go back anymore it's kind of cool
I guess make sure I don't get misleaded
misled what would I do with a bucket of
water take a bath in it splash it on my
face damn it both of those doors are
locked down to gallery what does that
mean what do you mean down to the
gallery there's nothing over there what
are you do sis what are you things what
what are you things it's a butter freely
that's a butterfly Wow um don't know how
to break this to you but that is the
worst butterfly I've ever seen
oh maybe I no I wouldn't think that
would be true that project the hell do I
do
damn it it's just going into circles do
not like I'm gonna water the plants or
something maybe there was some reason I
needed the bucket back in the same house
I was in before I don't know I'm
confused I'm confused root [ __ ] fruit
rabbit no what the hell do I do
wait a minute was another sign over here
did I read this butterfly park fine you
know what whatever I'm not even gonna
question at this point anymore
ah what do I do I'm a loss I've tried
everything haven't I
I've systematically tried everything
there's something else here I've been to
every corner of it what do I do
what does that say I don't know you
oh okay that was that you can't blame me
for that how is that even supposed to be
okay whatever I found it eventually got
a gallery key Honda's dick fantastic oh
look it's Gary oh look at Eve oh look
it's Pandora's box
well who's this I don't think I want to
open Pandora's box uh okay oh that was
the doll that's the little doll well
it's opening a box uh well nothing else
to do but open it whoa super powers
activated I let out the evils
little mirror what a mess Balu with a
little mirror maybe I can reflect the
sun's rays to melt the ice on the door
although I did just release the evil
your new come here butterfly is an eye
pattern on it well so what about that
should I get it
what is this huh put down Oh talk with
Gary you're holding on to your rose
right make sure you don't lose it don't
let anyone else have it although I still
wonder why do we have these roses well I
recall there was a rose sculpture in the
gallery called embodiment of spirit
wonder if it's good it was why is this
why is this the moment where I talked to
Gary I don't know what you have to say
and nothing okay whatever let's uh put
the mirror down fishing oh yeah the best
I know not too shabby
oh wow well this looks evil start with
the heart go do the hall I moon I need
to write this [ __ ] down good God
alrighty then Scholz the little bear
heart get the heart go to the eyeball go
please to the moon go down to the fun
pentagram Oh heart of evil go to the
green do dat sindelle twitter hole
o'clock and go to the upside down grin I
don't know how but mine turned out worse
than that one ah I mean I'm pretty
embarrassed about this this uh I didn't
think I could do any worse but I did so
there you have it but I got a written
down no matter what
ha ha ha Marga by our best ever bet
everything ok so I need to start with
the heart so those symbols are the ones
that got released from the box
there's the heart whoa girl that's a
heart look at that heart good stuff
I don't know I must babe I don't know
what to do
anyway I'll figure it out so anyway I'm
all on it no I'm not I'm not even close
to upset screw that I'm going on though
so what about that so what about the
thing whoa
excuse me excuse me are you serious
about no oh this all bloomed that's
lovely it's a single Apple up there how
do I get it I want it fine you know what
this freaky crap is can f off for all I
care their symbol in here no there's the
@ symbol yeah there's a spiral symbol I
don't think there'd be an engineer would
there be
ah no okay so I'm guessing I just need
to go hit all the symbols in a certain
order right right wrong cuz the eyes are
on that button okay the first one is
obviously the heart I go tag the heart
then I go look at the eye which is over
on the butterfly and then I go to the
moon which I think was on the lake come
here you [ __ ] ass butterfly here we go
I pattern good did that do anything
right pattern you know damn you're not
giving me much game I was doing so good
in the beginning of this game and then
all studies just coasted [ __ ] ah stare
deep into the water wing aha there we go
got it I can't escape from me now to the
Sun which is on the other side I don't
know where this satanic heart is I don't
know what that is tossed a Santa card
obviously but you know here we go you as
a standstill here Dan still
eeep sunbathing and nice but we gotta go
or we might not get to see the real Sun
again all right got that one where's
this psychobabble heart I don't know I
don't know I'm out of lost I'm just
wandering I'm just wandering I'm more
like gear or something here oh whoa
your new can't see you before where you
come from what the Wow what the hell
have that happened whoa whoa is there
more there like more
I'll tell me that's it oh there's a cat
drawn on the back of the sign well so
what about that a fall you gotta be
kidding yeah come on give me something
you bested you son of a [ __ ] oh no I
don't even know
I don't even know the Oh where's his
heart I don't know god damn it this is
really hard really hard
the clock is there that's not I don't
need that now I needed the other maybe I
just ruined it all because I went to
that one oh this is really hard
hey man over there Oh dingus
I guess I just need to maybe I don't
need to do it maybe I need to actually
unlock all the symbols first and then I
do it I don't know I know is these dang
ass things eat what is it did you find
something I think Gary doesn't see it
okay well so what about that ah so what
about that you're gonna you gonna Wow
[ __ ] yell man please leave me alone
ever ever mind
how do I can we get over to the dang gas
thing Steve I see that ya dingus you
know what dingus you um Dinka done or
mary go could you stab me in the butt
I'm tired of this
ha all right you know what I'll figure
this out later at a later date in the
future even
all right you know what up I'm gonna
figure this out later so anyway thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation with more videos that I've
done I'm sorry about the lack of
progress I'm really trying but I mean
it's are giving me anything I'm trying I
really am I'm using my brain it ain't
working so I'll figure it out of it
thank you all so much for watching a
little to put in literal bye bye
Oh
ah
Oh God
Oh
you